okay Donald Trump is going to mar-a-lago
this weekend his club and mansion in
Florida this is the third straight
weekend that he's going there each time
he goes there it cost taxpayers about
three million bucks but more importantly
it's Trump destroying his campaign
promise that he will not be taking
vacations and of course he said during
the campaign not only would he not take
vacations he would rarely leave the
White House quote I would rarely leave
the White House because there's so much
work to be done he said to a reporter in
2015 he also said something very similar
on a 60 minute interview no vacations
when he's president I believe it was was
Lesley Stahl that he was interviewed I
guess he can say he works during the
weekend at mar-a-lago or something you
know he had that situation with the
North Korean ballistic missile missile
test while he was at Morello go with
Japanese Prime Minister Shinzo Abe a but
again the cost of this is absolutely
crazy
and and by the way there's also security
concerns about the entire mar-a-lago
thing an investigation going on now into
the patio discussions with Shinzo Abe a
and advisers about the North Korean
ballistic missile launch membership at
mar-a-lago is 200 thousand bucks that's
not nothing but you're certainly
tempting foreign spies or countries to
say hey you know what we should try to
get one of our people in tomorrow logo
two hundred thousand bucks to be able to
hang around the guy with the nuclear
football and these high-level national
security discussions that's something a
lot of foreign countries can afford
oh I'm sure and they'll stay on at
Trump's hotel on Pennsylvania Avenue
when he's in DC those are both things a
Trump is not taking his presidential
salary of four hundred thousand dollars
but the weekly trips tomorrow Lago cost
three million dollars each Melania Trump
staying in New York is costing taxpayers
a million a day meanwhile Trump is
planning to reduce federal funding for
scientific computing and nuclear physics
research
once again Pennywise pound-foolish once
again we don't spend money except on my
personal stuff I guess the one thing is
he's reduced briefings to a single page
of mostly pictures plus a few
points so when you do that you do have
more time to hang out at mar-a-lago on
the golf course but it doesn't make me
feel particularly safe and this is going
to be a regular thing because they're
even calling mar-a-lago the winter white
house i'll i mean before when a
president would go on vacation i would
think well you know they're still kind
of working i mean there's a mobile
apparatus that can protect them yeah but
given trump's lack of work ethic can we
really expect that to be the case with
him no I mean his attention span is such
that even in the White House where we
hear to hearing from aides that he's
constantly just looking at TVs that are
on the wall instead of paying attention
to briefings if he's at his Golf Resort
in Florida how much work do we think is
getting done reminder double standard
reminder remember when conservatives
went completely apoplectic because
President Obama took a vacation day like
four months into his administration I
wonder where they are now that Trump is
vacationing every single weekend during
the first two months Trump got
inaugurated on a Friday and took the
weekend yeah because Monday's really the
beginning I mean who works on weekends